bonjour à tous et ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat tout au long du mois de
septembre je vous propose de voir et de
revoir les temps forts de la séance et
des auditions car en effet tout au long
du mois de septembre et bien les
sénateurs sont absents du Palais du
Luxembourg car ils sont en campagne à
l'occasion des élections sénatoriales
qui se tiendront le 28 septembre et qui
permettront de renouveler la moitié de
la Haute Assemblée retour ce matin à
l'audition de Pascal lami une audition
qui s'est déroulée le 7 mai dernier qui
a été tenue par la Commission des
Affaires économique du Sénat Pascal lami
a été longtemps collaborateur de Jacques
Delor il a été commissaire européen
pendant 5 ans puis il a été directeur
général de l'OMC l'Organisation mondiale
du commerce parcal l' mis aujourd'hui
président d'honneur du laboratoire
d'idée institut Jacques del lor notre
Europe un S tank qui comme tous les
stank auquel il participe est très
favorable à l'intégration européenne
Pascal lami a également été dernièrement
l'auteur d'un livre intitulé quand la
France s'éveillera un livre qui a pour
particularité de ne pas être purement
centré sur l'hexagone mais de présenter
les potentialités de la France vu du
monde tout de suite donc retour à cette
audition qui s'est tenue le 7 semain
dernier au Sénat vos fonctions votre
position vos compétences largement
reconnues font de vous un observateur
privilégié de la situation économique et
sociale de la France et de l'Europe car
la connaissance fine de ce qui se fait
ailleurs dans le monde vous permet de
voir sans doute autrement ce qui se fait
ici c'est ce regard à la fois proche et
distancié qui nous intéresse tout
particulièrement vous venez d'ailleurs
de publier un ouvrage dans le titre
exprime ambivalence de la situation de
notre pays euh de votre point de vue
quand la France s'éveillera ça nous
rappelle un autre titre ce ce titre
sonne à la fois comme un constat sévère
puisque si l'on s'éveille c'est bien
qu'on était endormi ou assoupi ou à tout
le moins suffisamment mobilisé en même
temps il exprime aussi un certain
optimiste quant à l'avenir de notre
économie et la force de nos atouts vous
dénoncez dans cet ouvrage la tendance de
certains en Europe et en France à céder
à ce que vous appelez la délectation
délectation
morosa j'ignore sil règne en Europe une
morosité ambiante un peu morbide mais il
existe un certain nombre d'indicateurs
objectif qui montre que tout ne va pas
pour le mieux croissance en berne
chômage élevé accroissement de la
pauvreté accroissement des inégalités
inversion de la tendance historique à la
réduction donc de ces inégalités de
revenus de patrimoine au sein de nos
société montter du vote d'extrême droite
dans nombre de pays européens à commencé
par le nôtre nous souhaitons donc vous
entendre sur votre diagnostic de la
situation économique de
l'Europe et si possible de la France y
a-t-il selon vous des facteurs de
blocage de la croissance européenne quel
regard portez-vous sur les politiques
économiques menées en Europe et en
France tout ça c'est un tout
agitons sur les bon levier qu'il soit
structurel ou
conjoncturel autrement dit se mobilise
ton sur les bons enjeux et les bonnes
priorités
et dernier point que sur lequel je
souhaiterais avoir votre sentiment après
avoir lu d'ailleurs un interview de vous
euh j'ai lu d'ailleurs votre analyse sur
les barrières non tarifairire euh qui
sont du domaine des valeurs et de la
précaution ce principe qui qui devrait
gérer les risques et non pas être
interprété comme une assurance du risque
zéro euh ceci bien entendu en vue des
négociations qui sont en cours entre les
États-Unis et l'Europe et les barrières
non tarifaires sont évidemment en
particulier je pense aux normes euh que
pourrait nous imposer les États-Unis par
rapport à nos pratiques concernant la
santé et l'environnement en Europe
voilà je vous laisse la parole et je
pense qu'après votre intervention il y
aura des échanges avec les sénateurs et
sénatrices merci merci monur
président merci pour cette invitation en
en préparant cette
discussion j'ai réalisé que c'était la
première fois depuis 40 ans
euh que j'apparaissais dans cette
maison libre de toute contrainte
institutionnelle et donc et donc avec
une
parole qui est ma seule responsabilité
et qui n'engage aucune des institutions
auxquelles j'ai appartenu dans
lesquelles j'ai travaillé que parfois
j'ai dirigé dans la République
française dans l'Union européenne ou au
niveau
international et pour tout dire ça fait
drôle mais c'est pas
désagréable j'espère que c'est un point
de vue que vous
partagerez je vais très brièvement
introduire la discussion puisque je ne
suis plus porteur d'une doctrine
institutionnelle d'un discours
institutionnel en en répondant aux deux
questions que vous venez de
poser d'abord sur le les perspectives de
l'économie européenne et ensuite sur
cette affaire de traité transatlantique
dont la négociation a commencé au mois
de juin de l'année
dernière pas anormal à la veille
d'élection européennes qu'on s'intéresse
à ce sujet enfin je dirais et je sais
que cette maison de ce point de vue a
toujours été une exception
euh le Sénat a toujours et c'est mon
expérience et je vous ai en donner une
indication de la durée de cette
expérience a toujours manifesté euh un
intérêt particulier pour les questions
européennes euh il y a un savoir-faire
une approche euh qui je le dois dire est
rare dans nos institutions et que j'ai
toujours en tout cas euh éprouvé comme
un soutien à l'intégration européenne
même si évidemment il peut y avoir des
nuances politiques ici ou là alors si on
prend la longue vue pour regarder non
pas sur le passé mais sur l'avenir en
gros les 10 années qui viennent
euh l'économie mondiale c'est euh 6 % de
croissance pour les pays en
développement dit
émergent c'est 3 % de croissance euh
pour les États-Unis et c'est euh 1 et5i
de croissance pour l'Europe toute chose
égal par
ailleurs autrement dit euh nos
perspectives à moyen long terme c'est la
moitié de la croissance américaine qui
est elle même la moitié de celle des
pays en
développement cette hiérarchie et le
produit euh de force euh qui sont celles
qui sont les grands facteurs euh qui
déterminent la croissance économique
dans le monde globalisé qui est le ntre
et en très gros
euh pourquoi ce 1 et5% européen euh très
simplement c'est la
somme de 2% de productivité globale des
facteurs par an qui est ce que nous
avons connu à peu près au cours des 10
dernières années disons c'est le haut de
la fourchette de la prévision moins 0,5
% qui est la baisse annuelle
tendantielle de la population active en
Europe donc la production
européenne la dynamique de production
européenne c'est la productivité globale
des facteurs plus la croissance des
facteurs sauf qu'il y a un des facteurs
qui décroit qui est la population
active et ce 2 % de
productivité en en projection moyenne et
longue je je le répète et le haut de la
fourchette donc ce 1 et5 % toute chose
égal par ailleurs c'est le haut de la
fourchette fait si la
productivité est à 1 dem% au lieu de 2 %
le taux de croissance à moyen terme de
l'Union européenne c'est 1
% c'est évidemment une perspective assez
sombre toute chose égale par
ailleurs notamment parce
que le
modèle de civilisation européenne ce
qu'on appelle entre nous Européens ce
modèle d'économie sociale de marché
n'est pas une économie de marché c'est
économie sociale de marché qui se
distingue d'autres modèles disponibles
sur la planète par un taux de
redistribution au titre du social que ce
soit l'éducation que ce soit la santé
que ce soit les retraites que ce soit le
logement nos pays
européens
dépensent beaucoup en redistribution
c'est c'est ce fameux chiffre que Madame
Merkel cite depuis 2 ans sur toutes les
tribunes l'Europe c'est 7 % de la
population mondiale 20 % de la
production mondiale et 50 % des dépenses
de sécurité sociale dans le
monde ce qui est une manière de dire que
c'est
beaucoup on peut et certains le feront
euh trouver que c'est tropp euh on peut
aussi ce qui est mon cas trouver que
c'est au fond ce qui fait notre vraie
identité européenne dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui et de demain à condition
d'accepter
que ce n'est soutenable comme modèle
qu'avec une croissance qui permet de le
nourrir quand vous avez une grosse
partie de votre économie qui fait
l'objet d'une redistribution
inévitablement le débat politique est
toujours assez vif sur les conditions de
ce
partage un problème que les Américains
par exemple n'ont pas
vraiment cont tenu de de leur système
économique et social chez nous
naturellement identitairement si je puis
dire cette question est importante et
mon sentiment pour ce qu' vaut c'est que
en gros en dessous de 2 % le système se
crispe au-dessus de 2 % le système
retrouve si je puis dire une respiration
normale on peut discuter hein tout ça
est très schématique mais je dis cela
parce que ce problème d'une faible
croissance européenne pour autant qu'on
puisse la prévoir et tout chose égal par
ailleurs n'est pas seulement un problème
économique c'est pas seulement un
problème conjoncturel c'est pas
seulement un problème de chômage et nous
savons que nous avons un taux de chômage
très important en moyenne en Europe
aujourd'hui même s'il est distribué de
manière un peu différente selon les pays
c'est ça va plus loin hein c'est un
problème en quelque sorte de nature
identitaire si nous ne trouvons pas un
chemin de croissance de l'ordre de 2 %
alors euh nos peuples euh dans leur
identité euh seront insatisfaits avec
les conséquences que cela
produit faiblesse et force en très très
gros euh de l'Union européenne euh dans
le monde contemporain euh on vient
d'identifier la première et la
principale des faiblesses euh qui est la
démographie euh nous sommes le seul
continent euh qui vieillit à ce point en
Europe dans les 10 ou 20 années qui
viennent nous seront d'ailleurs suivis
par la Chine dans les décennies qui
suivent qui paieront à ce moment-là
cette
politique
incroyablement
intrusive dans la nature humaine qui est
la
politique d'un enfant par ménage je
n'insiste pas là-dessus ces perspectives
sont connues deuxè faiblesse
structurelle dans le jeu des chaises
musi de la répartition des ressources
énergétiques l'Europe a été mal
dotée nous sommes de très très gros
importateurs d'énergie et ceci nous met
en quelque sorte en situation de
dépendance à la fois
stratégique mais aussi du point de vue
de la compétitivité dans la mesure où
les producteurs d'énergie ont tendance à
utiliser l'énergie la moins chère chez
eux et exporter une énergie légèrement
plus chère et c'est évidemment encore
plus vrai depuis la révolution du
gazochiste aux États-Unis qui reste dans
les 10 années
àenir notre concurrent principal 3ème
are de faiblesse qui elle n'est pas
structurelle mais qui est
malheureusement installé pour l'instant
qui est le le rétrécissement de la part
de la frontière technologique qui est
occupée
par les Européens dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui il y a 20 ou 30 ans
l'Europe occupait disons à peu près 30 %
de la frontière technologique les
Américains entre 40 et 50
%
aujourd'hui si on regarde ce qui se
passe dans les technologies de
l'information dans les nanotechnologies
dans les
biotechnologies de manière très
approximative la part que l'Europe
occupe dans cette frontière et de
l'ordre de 15 euh maximum 20 % les
États-Unis sont probablement à 60 % et
un certain nombre de pays émergents
commencent à occuper si je peux dire les
10 ou 15 % euh qu'il sur lesquels ils
pénètrent au fur et à mesure que leur
niveau
d'édocation d'élaboration de la
propriété intellectuelle de production
d'ingénieur
s'élève ça n'est pas
irrémédiable mais c'est une tendance
lourde euh dont nous devons bien être
conscient parce que
les produits de demain ce qui fera
l'objet de l'activité économique de ce
que les consommateurs rechercheront de
ce que les producteurs de biens et de
services devront satisfaire ce sont des
choses de plus en plus immatérielles
dans lequel si je puis dire de manière
vulgaire le contenu en Jul cervel
devient de plus en plus important et le
contenu en huile de coude de moins en
moins important et ceci évidemment est
un enjeu crucial du point de vue des
systèmes de
formation
dernier facteur de faiblesse qui elle
aussi n'est pas structurel mais qui est
là c'est la
relative faible productivité du secteur
des services en Europe si vous comparez
par exemple la productivité de
l'économie américaine et de l'économie
européenne les Américains jouissent d'un
avantage comparatif important en matière
de prix des services parce qu'ils ont un
marché intérieur des services hauteur
d'une population de consommateur qui est
bien moins important que la nôtre mais
leur marché de service est un marché
intérieur alors que nous savons qu'au
niveau européen ça n'est fait
aujourd'hui que à quelque chose de
l'ordre de 30 à 40 % et encore alors que
c'est fait disons à l'ordre de 80 à 90 %
dans les biens ceci va plus loin que la
considération du seul secteur des
services dans la mesure où où l'économie
moderne intègre de manière de plus en
plus considérable l'industrie et les
services c'est très difficile dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui et à forcerie dans
le monde de demain de faire une
frontière entre ce qui est de
l'industrie ce qui est des services et
si vous regardez la valeur ajoutée de
beaucoup d'objets disons d'artefacts qui
ressemble à des produits industriels
aujourd'hui en réalité vous apercevez
que l'essentiel de la valeur ajoutée ce
sont des services hein si si pr V
tablette ou le téléphone mobile avec
lequel Marie Noël est en train de
consulter internet et bien si on prend
ce petit objet ça ressemble ça ressemble
à un produit industriel hein une usine
qui a produit ça simplement là-dedans il
y a 5 % de valeur ajoutée industriel qui
est le truc en plastique éventuellement
en aluminium il y a la valeur des terres
rares qu' ont été manipulé pour faire
les puces qu'il y a làdedans et le reste
c'est tout du j cervel c'est des
programmes c'est des brevets c'est du
design c'est de la
distribution face à ça où sont les
forces il y a une force
essentielle qui est celle que nous
devons nous Européens exploiter
davantage qui est notre masse notre
taille qui est la la largeur et la prof
profondeur et la profondeur de notre
marché que ce soit dans la concurrence
internationale ou que ce soit dans
l'obtention des progrès de
productivité qui sont
disponibles alors si je regarde encore
une fois à un niveau très planétaire
cette masse l'Europe l'utilise
correctement dans ce qui est la gestion
de la concurrence
internationalein au cours des 10
dernières années les pars de marché
international de l'Europe n'ont
pratiquement pas bougé alors que les
États-Unis et celle des États-Unis et du
Japon se sont très nettement
effrité et donc globalement globalement
la gestion par l'Europe de sa relation
avec l'économie internationale la mesure
dont elle respire avec cette économie en
terme d'exportation et d'importation au
niveau européen et de bonne
qualité par contre c'est vrai que comme
je dit il y a un problème de
productivité qui est largement lié au
marché intérieur des services donc ceci
en quelque sorte nous
donne et de manière très schématique
nous donne une espèce de feuille de
route dans ces cas-là il faut combler
ses faiblesses et exploiter ses atouts
combler la faiblesse démocratique
démographique c'est pas commode on
connaît tous la solution historique elle
est parfaitement disponible c'est
l'immigration c'est toujours comme ça
que ça s'est passé dans l'histoire à
ceci près que nous savons que ça se
heurte à des réticence dont certaines
sont culturelles et d'autres d'autres de
nature plus politique c'est évidemment
c'est évidemment la solution sur le plan
théorique reste effectivement mesurer la
distance qu'il y a parfois entre la
théorie et la faisabilité politique mais
il faudra de toute façon
il faudra de toute façon que l'Europe
importe de la force de travail à terme
de 10 ou 20 ans si elle veut maintenir
le modèle d'économie sociale de marché
qui est le sien en matière d'énergie on
sait comment disons sur le plan
théorique remédier à un certain nombre
de faiblesses de l'Europe ça s'appelle
la transition énergétiqu ça s'appelle
des économies renouvelables ça s'appelle
l'efficacité énergétique c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles l' si je puis dire est depuis
longtemps à la pointe
de de un certain nombre de d'actions
internationales en matière de
d'environnement de changement climatique
d'émission de G efferc et d'économie
d'énergie mais nous savons aussi que il
reste énormément à faire tant si je puux
dire la notion de politique énergétique
commune européenne est encore très très
fumeuse étant disons chacun des modèles
nationaux que ce soit le recours aux
énergies fossil par rapport au
renouvelabl que ce soit les problèmes de
gestion des prix de cette énergie que ce
soit les problèmes de gestion de
l'augmentation de l'efficacité
énergétique sont encore sur un spectre
très très différent je n'insiste pas sur
ce point qui est évident sur la
frontière technologique là aussi la
solution théorique est assez bien connue
hein il faut il faut
investir dans l'avenir et il faut
investir dans l'avenir avec des ticket
de plus en plus gros tout en sachant que
seulement une partie du ticket investi
est porteur de découverte d'innovation
de développement sur les marchés mais
que vous regardiez l'industrie
pharmaceutique que vous regardiez les
industries
de l'industrie de l'information que ce
soit tout ce qui est autour de
l'économie dégétale on voit bien que il
n'y a plus pratiquement au niveau de la
production final il n'y a plus que des
éléphants qui ont bâti leur succès sur
des visions des recherches mais avec des
mises en capitaux pour ce qui est du
système de production considérable et
donc ça veut dire que c'est aussi un
domaine où en théorie nous devrions nous
pourrions bénéficier de notre effet
d'échelle à condition de concentrer
l'excellence et de ne pas la disperser
et nous savons tous que disons dans
l'entreprise inégration européenne
notamment sur les programmes de
recherche il y a quand même une certaine
tendance à faire plaisir à tout le monde
et donc à éparvier un peu les moyens
alors qu'en réité il faudra les
concentrcrer ce qui suppose une volonté
politique particulièrement
déterminée sur les forces j'en ai parlé
c'est essentiellement le marché
intérieur dans dans les services qui
pourrait être source de productivité et
donc à terme
d'emploi nous savons tous qu'à court
terme la productivité c'est du
changement d'emploi nous savons tous
qu'à long terme la productivité c'est de
l'emploi et comme par hasard d'ailleurs
ce sont les économies les plus
productives et les plus compétitive qui
ont le taux de chômage le plus bas je
n'insiste pas sur ce point qui est
parfois chez nous un peu perdu
de donc là je me suis limité au champ
européen bien entendu si on si on
regarde par exemple les problèmes que la
France a affronté hélas depuis très
longtemps en matière de équipes de
publique en matière de chômage de masse
en matière d'érosion de la
compétitivité les 2 tiers
euh des solutions à ces questions ne
sont pas d'ordre européen elles sont
d'ordre national la preuve d'ailleurs
c'est qu'à l'intérieur du même cadre
avec la même politique commerciale
commune avec les mêmes institutions avec
la même politique macro-économique pour
autant qu'il y en a une il y a des
performances très très différentes à la
fois sur les finances publiques sur le
chômage et sur la compétitivité donc ça
ça nous dit que quand même l'essentiel
ça se passe au niveau domestique au
niveau national mais évidemment
l'échelon européen peut-être important
en tant que catalyseur et en tant que
niveau pertinent pour des économies
d'échelle qui s'agit des investissements
dans les infrastructures qui s'agitent
de la Recherche Développement qui
s'agisse même de programmes comme ceux
qui sont apparus au cours des dernières
années pour lutter contre le chômage de
jeunes avec des systèmes d'apprentissage
de type
erasmous le tout étant effectivement une
question de
dosage l'Europe passe par une phase de
désendettement qui à mon avis était
nécessaire je n'appelle pas cela de
l'austérité j'appelle ça du
désendettement euh mais il est vrai
aussi que nous ne faisons pas ensemble
assez
d'investissement dans ce que dans ce qui
constitue les programmes d'avenir et je
pense que ça c'est vraiment une question
majeure pour la prochaine législature
européenne euh après que les électeurs
européens auront déterminé le rapport
des forces politiques au Parlement
européen et donc dans une certaine
mesure et moyennant les discussions
nécessaires entre le Conseil européen et
le Parlement européen la composition de
la commission
européenne donc voilà pour ce qui est de
votre première question monsieur le
Président sur
euh le traité
transatlantique en un mot et on pourra y
revenir en fonction de vos question
euh ce cette négociation s'inscrit dans
un
basculement considérable
historique à la fois du commerce
international et de la régulation du
commerce international hein si vous
voulez le la régulation du commerce
international a pour
objet de réduire ou d'éliminer les
obstacles aux échanges pour autant qu'il
soit illégitime ce qui suppose une
définition consensuelle de ce que ça
veut dire d'illégitime mais disons euh
le le la base idéologique et d'ailleurs
celle ciment idéologique des des membres
de l'UMC c'est que en gros l'ouverture
des échanges ça marche parce que ça
permet à chacun de faire davantage de ce
en quoi il ou elle est bon et de faire
faire par les autres ce que là où ils
sont bons vieille théorie toute simple
ricardienne qui peut faire l'objet de
modèle économique très compliqué mais
disons qui se comprend assez bien c'est
ça c'est l'efficience qui fait de la
croissance et donc potentiellement de la
productivité j'ai consacré d'ailleurs à
ce sujet un petit livre mais qui est en
anglais que j'ai publié l' dernière à
Cambridge University Press qui fait le
tour de la question ceux d'entre vous
qui veulent approfondir savent que je
suis toujours disponible j'ai passé trop
de temps de ma vie dans ce dans ce
métier pour ne pas il en avoir
garder petite expérience et en tout cas
une certaine
affection réduire les obstacles aux
échanges depuis en gros 2
millénaires depuis que le premier traité
de commerce a été signé entre le roi de
Crète et le pharaon d'Égypte ça
consistait à réduire des mesures qui
étaient des obstacles à l'échange et
dont l'objet était de protéger les
producteurs nationaux de la concurrence
étrangère pour diverses raisons type
droit de
Douine ce monde est en train de mourir
se terminer il est comme comme comme ces
étoiles dont on perçoit encore la
lumière non pas parce que elles existe
elles sont mortes mais la lumière met un
certain temps à arriver jusqu'à nos yeux
les droits dou en gros c'est ça
historiquement pourquoi tout simplement
parce que la technologie la glob
cette phase là de globalisation conduit
à une multilocalisation des processus de
production au fond on
est j'ai développé cette doctrine quand
j'étais directeur général de l'OMC on
est dans une époque où les chaudes ne
sont plus made in France made in Germany
made in Japan made in China made in the
world 60 % du commerce international
sont des composants ou des pièces
détachées le contenu en importation des
exportations moyens dans le monde était
20 % il y a 20 ans c'est 40 %
aujourd'hui ce sera 60 % dans 20 ans et
donc cette interpénétration qui au fond
est en train de détruire la notion de
frontière de ce point de
vue suit son cours et et pour cette
raison c'est c'est bien sûr qu'il a des
disciplines que compris de l'OMC permis
de de passer en tout
cas de ne
pas céder à des tentation à des pulsions
et donc à pas produire de choc
protectionnistes dire le commerce
international a remarquablement résisté
à la crise économique mais c'est pas ça
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est qu'à
partir du moment où plus de la moitié de
vos exportations dépendent de votre
contenu en importation shooter dans vos
importations ça veut dire démolir la
compétitivité exportation c'est aussi
simple que cela donc ce mondeel est en
train de se terminer est-ce que pour
autant le commerce est libre
non parce que il subsiste et se
multiplie d'autres obstacles au commerce
d'une autre nature c'est ce que vous
appeliez à juste titre les barrières non
tarifaires euh qui sont le produit de
réglementation nationale souvent
européenne dans le cas européen qui qui
sont destinés à protéger non pas le
producteur de la concurrence étrangère
mais le consommateur de risque
divers et qui donc tourne autour de la
notion de
précaution qui établissent et
administrent un niveau de précaution qui
s'agisse de la sécurité des aliment des
des critères de crash test pour les
voitures de la sécurité des jouets des
briquets de la protection des données
privées du régime prudentiel des banques
et des assurances et j'en
passe ces mesures se multiplient dans le
monde au fur et à mesure que disons le
progrès et le développement permet à des
femmes et à des hommes de se préoccuper
d'autres choses que savoir si eux ou
leurs enfants vont manger le lendemain
ce qui est finalement une assez bonne
nouvelle on s'intéresse à des choses qui
sont de l'ordre des
valeurs simplement se faisant on
juxapose des échelles de valeur qui sont
parfois très
différentes et donc la question de
l'avenir en terme de régulation de
l'échange international ça n'est plus de
réduire ou d'éliminer ces obstacle même
personne ne
va
changer son standard de maximum de
résidus de pesticides dans les fleurs
coupé pour favoriser le commerce
internation tion aucun Parlement ne
ratifiera
ça et donc le le jeu n'est plus de
d'éliminer ces obstacles il est
d'éliminé ce qui fait problème
c'est-à-dire la différence entre ces
obstacle ça c'est un exercice évidemment
beaucoup plus compliqué qui est de
l'ordre la convergence
réglementaire concept d'ailleurs que les
que les Européens connaissent assez bien
parce que c'est au fond ce qui a fait la
différence entre le le marché commun
d'avant 92 et le marché intérieur
d'après 92 quelle est la différence
c'est en gros de la convergence
réglementaire sur les normes et les
standards c'est évidemment encore une
fois un enjeu très très différent il est
en partie encadré par les règles de
l'OMC et notamment par l'accord sur les
barrières techniques au commerce et par
l'accord sur les mesures sanitaires et
phytosanitaires mais il n'est encadré
que dans les principes les les
organisations les organes de régulation
aussi bien au niveau national qu'au
niveau international quand il y en a qui
sont responsables de ces normes de ces
standards ne sont pas des organes
commerciaux hein ce sont des organes
parfois scientifiques parfois technique
mais le
l'idée parmi ces
régulateurs dont l'objectif est de et la
protection et la
précaution l'idée que que ils vont
négocier entre eux des standards communs
que ce soit pour les harmoniser ou que
ce soit pour en accepter la
reconnaissance mutuelle est une idée
assez compliquée et ça c'est l'objet de
ce traité transatlantique si vous
regardez les échanges euro-américains
c'est à peu près 1000 milliards de
dollars par an la partie marchandise
bien de ce commerce qui est soumis à les
droits de douanes est assez faible le
droit de douane moyen entre les
États-Unis et l'Europe aujourd'hui c'est
de l'ordre de 2 2 et5 % donc l'ouverture
de l'échange transatlantique qui fait du
sens du point de vue de des gains
d'efficience c'est
% de la convergence
réglementaire ça consiste à faire en
sorte que les voitures américaines et
les voitures européennes et les mêmes
standards de sécurité que les crash test
soient sinon identiques du moins
équivalent que on se mette d'accord sur
la norme de
déchlorination des poulets parce qu'on
sait bien qu'il faut laver les poulets
quand on produit des dans des usines à
poulet il va falloir se mettre d'accord
sur les questions de protection des
données privées tout sujet qui sont pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux très
sensibles très délicats parce que la
manière dont vous percevez le risque et
la manière dont vous gérez la précaution
est assez étroitement corrélée avec une
échelle de valeur
un risque c'est quoi c'est quelque chose
si ça se produit c'est moins bien que si
ça se produit pas il y a tout de suite
du bien et du mal dans la symbolique qui
s'exerce en gestion de la
précaution et et ça c'est je crois une
question majeure
et mon sentiment et là je vais
m'expriquer je m'exprimer avec
précaution pour pour mes propos ne
provoque pas de problème mon sentiment
c'est que
cette négociation a été
lancée comme une négociation
classique au
fond il y a la chose et il y a le nom on
lui a donné un nom on l'a associé à un
narratif qui ressemble à un accord
classique comme l'Union européenne en a
signé avec la Corée
avec avec le Canada récemment et comme
les États-Unis on on signé avec les
paysamérique latine bon or c'est un
animal de nature différente et et la
différence de cette nature à mon avis
mériterait d'être mieux expliqué mieux
souligné ne seraitce ne seraitce que
pour répondre à des questions
légitimes qui viennent d'ailleurs des
deux côtés comme par hasard et qui
consiste à se demander si une telle
convergence va se
faire au détriment de la précaution il
peut y avoir des soupçons légitimes et
notamment en Europe que finalement
l'Europe est un continent très
précautionneux que les États-Unis sont
un continent beaucoup
plus beaucoup
plus habitué au risque et que donc ceci
va se faire au détriment d'un niveau de
précaution auquel disons les Européens
tiennent pour des raisons
identitaires je crois qu'il faut il faut
regarder ça avec un peu de recul hein il
y a des tas d'endroits et j'en connais
tas de secteurs techniques où la
précaution américaine est supérieure à
la précaution
européenne prend prendre qu'un exemple
il y a pas de voiture diesel aux
États-Unis il y a des camions diesel
parce que le syndicat des camionneurs
est suffisamment fort pour obtenir ça
pour les camions mais pas pour les
voitures et pourquoi parce que c'est pas
bon pour l'environnement d'
historiquement ce sont les Américains
qui ont inventé le proc principe de
précaution dans les années 70 avec le
cleanerct alors que à l'époque l'Europe
était sur le logiciel po payer qui est
exactement le contraire de la précaution
auquel nous sommes venus après et donc
ça c'est un enjeu important mon
sentiment
personnel c'est que cette négociation
qui sera
longue complexe euh qui donne lieu à
beaucoup de débats et il faut compte
tenu de la sensibilité des sujets
abordés qu'elle donne mieux à débat et à
transparence mon sentiment euh c'est
qu'à la fin euh ça s'alignera sur le
niveau de précaution le plus élevé de
chacun des deux
côtés je ne vois pas personnellement
c'est mon expérience de négociateur
commercial dans ces domaines même si ce
sont des domaines qui ont été moins
négociés que les obstacles précédents je
pense que c'est comme ça que ça
terminera euh simplement c'est très
difficile tactiquement quand on démarre
une
négociation de dire bon benah finalement
ça va être simple on va prendre le
niveau de précaution le plus élevé des
deux
côtés sans comme ça rentrer dans la
technique parce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire dans la pharmacie dans la
chimie dans l'automobile dans
l'agroalimentaire ce serait au fond la
manière la plus simple de de d'obtenir
l'objectif mais on sent bien que pour
des raisons tactiques et politiques
cette suggggestion est un peu utopique
mais je crois que c'est dans cet esprit
là qu'il faut se placer j'en termine là
pour laisser autant de place que
possible à vos
questions
merci et donc Monsieur
vugrenard Merci monsieur le
Président je voulais vous interroger
monsieur l'ami sur les les quelques
points que vous avez
aborder également sur les quelques
déclarations que vous avez faites ces
dernières semaines mais venons-en
d'abord au point vous avez abordé
notamment sur les les différences entre
le la France l'Europe et le reste du
monde en quelque sorte vous avez indiqué
que la croissance des pays émergents
dans les années à venir de 6 % ça 3% en
Europe
1% les questions de productivité certes
sont à prendre en considération et sont
importantes de la même
manière des
investissements dans le cadre de la rech
marché d'innovation on voit combien ils
sont différents en France avec le reste
de l'Europe et encore plus avec les pays
émergents et les États-Unis il une
question qui n'a pas été abordée c'est
les questions aussi monétaires il nous
est arrivé d'auditionner Louis Galois
lorsqu'il avait un responsabilité EADS
et fréquemment il nous disait la
différence de parité entre le dollar et
l'euro nous pose manifestement des
problèmes concurrentiells qui sont qui
sont importants ne pensez-vous pas que
la Banque centrale européenne
euh devrait être plus audacieuse en
matière de politique monétaire pour
faire diminuer la parité de l'euro face
au
dollar une note récente de de de Bercy
euh indique les avantages de la
dévaluation de l'euro si l'euro était
dévalué de 10 % ça pourrait entraîner la
première année une augmentation du
produit intérieur brut de notre pays de
0,6 % au bout de la 3e année 1,2 % avec
les conséquences au niveau de l'emploi
qui serait chiffré à 30000 emplois
supplémentaires la première année 150000
la 3e année les chiffres sont toujours
sujets à caution bien entendu mais ça
mérite quand même qu'on qu'on en
débattre et j'aimerais avoir votre point
de vue sur cette question là deuxè
aspect vous avez été directeur général
de l'Organisation mondiale du commerce
et vous venez d'évoquer les questions de
convergence
élémentaire j'ai toujours été étonné et
beaucoup d'autres bien entendu et
notamment la Confédération européenne du
syndicat sur le fait qu'on acceptait des
pays venir à l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce sans avoir des exigences
élémentaires par rapport à leur
acceptation des critères minimum
déterminé par l'Organisation
internationale du travail ce qui
manifestement a pour conséquence un
dumping social évident et c'était le
sujet à l'ordre du jour de la Haute
Assemblée hier avec une concurrence
déloyale qui va également dans le même
sens donc j'ai toujours été surpris donc
quels ont été les obstacles qui font que
on ne peut pas exiger on est on a pas
exigé tout au moins les normes minimum
imposées par l'Organisation
internationale du travail avant
d'accepter qu'un pays rejoigne
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce avec
les avantages manifestes que cela avait
3ème point euh monsieur l'ami je veux
revenir sur les déclarations que vous
avez fait dernièrement indiquant
notamment que euh il était peut-être
utile de mettre en place un SMIC jeune
et donc des petits boulot
entre 2008 et 2011 en pleine période
donc de crise économique financière et
et sociale dans notre pays il faut
savoir que 10 % des plus pauvres ont vu
leur pouvoir d'achat diminuer de 3,4 %
entre 2008 et 2011 dans la même période
les 5 % les plus forttinés de notre pays
ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat croître de
3,5 %. je rappeler deux autres chiffres
10 % des plus riches aujourd'hui sur
notre territoire à qu' part 50 % du
patrimoine national 50 % des moins
fortunés s'en partage 7
% donc la question selon moi qui se pose
une question plus de redistribution
finalement des richesses
globales des efforts partagés entre ceux
qui ont la possibilité de faire des
efforts plutôt que de s'attaquer aux
jeunes qui vont probablement être la
génération de pris l'après guerre qui
risque de vivre moins bien que
l'ensemble des générations qui les ont
précédé et donc plutôt que de demander
des efforts aux jeunes je pense que
d'abord il y a des efforts
intergénérationnels qui irit dans un
sens opposé et que par ailleurs il y a
bien d'autres efforts à faire que cela
donc pour tout dire et pour conclure
parce que je sens le président
s'impatienté je le comprends je je
trouve monsieur l'ami je le dis en toute
courtoisie vos déclarations sur cet
aspect là je pense d'abord que c'est à
l'évidence une mauvaise solution je
trouve ces déclarations un peu
iconoclastes et pour tout dire et
Laurence Pariso n'est pas considéré
comme étant une affreuse gauchiste
elle-même disait suite aux déclarations
de Monsieur Gatas que baiser le SMIC
serait de l'esclavage donc voilà à un
moment où les profits et les
augmentations de des patrons du C 40
sont
extrêmement sensibles dans cette période
de crise je trouve qu'il était
inconvenant de faire ce genre de
déclaration merci Yannick Monsieur Bruno
rotillo j'ai deux questions à à vous
poser la première ça concerne ce que on
peut espérer en terme de croissance
potentielle parce que entre les lignes
vous nous avez donné la définition de ce
qu'on appelle la croissance potentielle
c'est-à-dire le produit euh de la
démographie active et avec le progrès
autrement dit de façon plus
technocratique la productivité globale
des facteurs ce que on appelle dans le
langage courant le le progrès et quand
on a et on fait en France le produit de
ces deux données on n'obtient pas le
chiffre que vous annoncez européen on
obtient moins de 1 %. on obtient moins
de 1 % c'est à peu près le consensus euh
des économistes donc on est loin euh des
des chiffres même que vous sembliez
annoncer euh pour différentes raisons
mais je je vous pose cette question
est-ce que vous pensez vraiment que la
croissance potentielle est à 1 et5i pour
la France pour les deux ou trois
prochaines années ou est-ce que la
croissance potentiel est plutôt à 1
voire 0,8 ou ou 0,9 %. c'est important
pour un Simp de de débat que que nous
avons et notamment pour la fameuse
trajectoire budgétaire la deuxème
question
euh vous appartenez donc à ces haut
fonctionnaires qui ont sillonné le monde
euh la France sans doute était un peu un
peu lointaine dans dans dans vos
préoccupations du du village global vous
avez sûrement lu le dernier livre
d'Hubert Vedrine voyez je choisis mes
mes auteurs et Hubert Vedrine dit à un
moment donné il ne faudrait pas que
l'Europe devienne l'idiot du village
global bon
euh je d'ailleurs cette question rejoint
un peu la question sur l'aspect
monétaire que yanck vourganard a appelé
il y a il y a quand même ce qui me
choque bien sûr les théories pour tous
ceux qui ont fait qui se sont et qui se
passionnent toujours pour la science
économique qu' on connaît les théories
ricardiennes mais on sait aussi que
entre la théorie et et la pratique il y
a parfois des béances il y a des
souffrances euh et on doit observer que
mettre en concurrence directe des
populations où les enfants travaillent
où on a un quasi esclavage avec des
populations de travailleurs où on a
intégré dieu merci un haut niveau de
protection sociale à un niveau au niveau
de protection
environnementale ça peut peut-être
marcher en théorie mais vous avez en
pratique d'énormes clashes alors moi je
suis parfaitement d'accord avec vous sur
le fait que la multiplication des
échanges internationaux euh je suis
passionné par le numérique donc je sais
très bien que ça crée plus
d'interdépendance et je suis pour cette
interdépendance mais il faut aussi
réintroduire un peu de concret un peu de
réel parce que on n'est pas dans un
village virtuel et je je pense que quand
par exemple on va faire on essaie de
faire des efforts c'est plutôt positifs
d'ailleurs globalement pour réduire le
coût du travail en France mais Queen
même temps avec le yen remibi qui est
une
monnaie très
sous-évaluée que le dollar est aussi une
sous-évaluée enfin à quoi à quoi servent
nos efforts évidemment dans la zone euro
ça peut fonctionner mais au-delà il y a
il y a cette il y a cet aspect on on a
tous encore à l'esprit ce qui s'est
passé pour le photovoltaïque où l'Europe
franchement vis-à-vis de la Chine a
capitulé on a monté les muscles mais on
a capituler bon bref on sait aussi sur
le dernier Farm Bill américain où la
façon d'aider les agriculteurs désormais
passe par des régime assurentiel que
nous nous n'avons pas face aux aléas
climatiques qui sont des grands un un
des grands changements mondiaux
aujourd'hui lait dans le monde hier ce
qui se passe en Floride mais ce qui peut
se passer en vandé avec xintiia c'est la
même chose on sait ce qui se passe d'un
bout à l'autre du monde finalement donc
voilà jeux tempérer je veux dire que je
je pense qu'il faut travailler
inlassablement sur la réduction d'un
certain nombre d'écarts sur une
convergence réglementaire mais il faut
réintroduire du réel parce que si on
réintroduit pas à un moment donné le
réel et pour reprendre ce que disait
Vedrine on on risque de venir avec des
TH théories extrêmement brillantes avec
beaucoup d'intelligence vraiment les
idiots du village
planétaire merci Marie Noë
linman plusieurs réaction la première
réaction c'est euh quel bilan peut-on
tirer de du grand mouvement de
libéralisation mondiale dire est-ce
qu'on en fait un un bilan positif
globalement positif ou est-ce qu'on est
capable d'avoir un un regard critique en
disant certes il y a eu des échanges
améliorés il y a eu l'émergence de
certains pays et cetera et des classes
moyenne dans ces pays mais enfin en même
temps j'observe que depuis qu'il a la
libéralisation des mouvements de
capitaux les paradis fiscaux ne cesse de
croître et embelllir et contrairement à
tout ce qu'on raconte ça continue que
par ailleurs les États qui certes
pouvaient avoir des temp des prurites
nationalistes mais qui quand même
incarnaient une certaine souveraineté
populaire nous sommes des républicains
nous croyons à la souveraineté populaire
qu'elle soit française européenne
mondiale enfin on pense que c'est quand
même les peuples qui déterminent leur
leur destin et ben c'est fini puisque
les multinationales n'ont vu leur
pouvoir que
se que les normes internes les normes
internes qu'elles mettent sont parfois
plus importantes que les normes est
dicté par les puissances publiques hein
donc par rapport à cela moi je je
constate quand même que le bilan de
cette libéralisation généralisée n'est
pas positif les inégalités se sont accru
euh au sein des grands pays et et
parfois au sein des grandes zones comme
l'EUR l'Europe euh et je ne vois pas ce
qui va inverser la donne même si je vois
avec bonheur que les Chinois font des
grves pour avoir de la sécurité sociale
et cetera mais enfin avant que le
dernier des Chinois et des des mecs du
de l'fasie et obtenu un minimum de
règles sociales on a le temps d'avoir
perdu toutes les notes quoi donc il y a
ce problème donc moi je pense que le
concept de juste échange qui doit doit
être porté au niveau mondial doit
trouver des formes de concrétisation
rapide parce que on ne peut pas nier que
les tendances nationalistes se
développent pas partout en Inde en Chine
en Russie en en Europe et moi je veux
bien votre vision idylique mais il y a
des choc de l'histoire qui souvient
souvent viennent en écho d'une
incapacité à régler des choses
économiques deuxièmement l'Europe al moi
il se trouve que vous le savez depuis
les années 80 je suis de près ces
affaires et je suis une Européenne
convaincu force de constater que plus
temps va plus le temps passe
plus je suis déçu et plus je considère
qu'on m'a menti j'ai j'ai écouté le
Livre blanc de Ja de l' chaque fois on
nous promettait des millions d'emplois
des que plus on libéralisait tout ça
allait aller très bien pu alors quand ça
va pas bien parce que le chômage
augmente que les inégalités entre pays
du nord du sud et cetera se développe on
dit on y va pas encore assez c'est parce
qu'on n pas été au bout de la
libéralisation que tout ça ne marche pas
et vous étonnez après que les peuples ne
soient pas motivés sur les élections
européennes et que ils ne croi plus en
mais absolument plus dans les discours
qu'on leur vend sur l'Europe donc par
exemple vous
déclarz c'est un problème national parce
qu' il y a des pays qui s'en tient bien
et d'autres qui s'en tirent mal et oui
sauf que le cadre qui a été fixé il est
favorable à certains il est favorable à
d'autres alors certes la France aurait
dû réagir avec beaucoup plus de
véhément sur par exemple le Calc le
système des aides publiques pour les
entreprises mais tout a été fait pour
que la France qui était historiquement
et c'est là où l'Europe il y a la
domination d'un certain nombre de
cultures au détriment d'autres qu'on a
laissé faire le génie français
historiquement c'est quand même du
capital public des aides publ un lien
entre l'innovation individuelle la PME
les secteurs industriel le capitalisme
familial et le capitalisme public et
c'est pas pour faire du Montebourg mais
depuis depuis Colbert plus plus de
Gaulle plus mitteran et puis vous prenez
les sondages aujourd'hui 80 % des
Français voudrait qu'on renationalise
Alstom alors moi je veux bien qu'on soit
qu'un pays de crrétin qui rien compris
au libéralisme mais on sait très bien
que chaque peuple a son génie et on a
expliqué en Europe que le génie français
était disqualifié parce que l'idéologie
dominante c'était le libéralisme
généralisé et pas d'être publi je ne dis
pas qu'il fallait garder les mêmes
nationalisations et cetera mais il
fallait avoir une nous laisser l'espace
d'une mutation non suppression des aides
publiques privatisation
est pas entier de l'industrie
disparaisse et après on on dit ah les
Allemands sont géniaux forcément le
système est construit pour eux le refor
les favorise bon donc moi je veux bien
ça je constate que les autres pays
d'Europe du Sud sont dans une situation
il y a pas que nous les brê et c'est pas
parce qu' le soleil au sud qu'on est
crétin et qu'au nord parce qu'ils ont
froid ils sont intelligents parce que je
crois que là ce n'est pas cela donc moi
je ce que je vois c'est quand vous
parlez de la démographie euh euh par
exemple quand vous dites il faut de
l'immigration je suis pour l'immigration
je pense qu'un pays qui ne s'émigre plus
ne respire plus mais vous dites il va
bien falloir des forces de travail mais
est-ce que la première priorité ce
serait pas de dire que le plein emploi
est un objectif numéro 1 des europé
et qu'on se donne les moyens et que
force de constater que les méthodes qu't
jusqu'à présent été mises en œuvre n'ont
pas permis le plein emploi je sais bien
que les chômeurs sont tous défeignants
qu'on est que des crétins en France mais
enfin il me semble quand même qu'il y a
un problème sur dernière chose
intuitivement le modèle que vous prenez
celui des libéraux c'est chacun va faire
ce qu'il est capable de faire j'attends
avant que le Niger se développe he les
gars alors heureusement ils ont de
l'uranium et autre mais je ne crois pas
à cela je crois à l'écosystème humain je
ne crois pas qu'il y a dans une société
on doit faire que ce qu'on est sur quoi
on est bon pour être pour faire on a
besoin qu'il y en a qui soi moins bon
autour de soi parce que c'est aussi ça
qui crée de l'innovation quand vous
parlez de la crise de l'innovation et je
ne suis pas d'accord avec Guillaume
Sarkozi vous le savez bien qui est le
patron historique qui était à l'époque
le patron du textile mais quand ils ont
expliqué les industriels français du
textile que quand on allait délocaliser
le textile une part de l'innovation
allait partir pourquoi parce qu'on ne
sait pas quand on innove si on va
innover sur la fibre sur la manière de
tisser sur la manière de traiter le
tissu comment on introduit dans des
choses vieilles comme le monde des
modernités totales et quand on perd la
diversité de ce tissu là on perd les
capacités d'innovation ou alors on fait
ce qu'on fait en France c'estàdire de la
recherche fondamentale et après quand il
s'agit de penser comment tout ça peut
rentrer dans l'innovation on n'y arrive
pas donc le modèle de société qui vise à
spécialiser les gens là où ils sont bons
et surtout là où comme le disait ma
collègue à droite tout à l'heure en
discutant là où ils sont le moins chers
et Ben est un modèle suicidaire parce
qu'il ne correspond pas à l'écosystème
humain voilà donc moi je pense que quand
même la remise en cause de de cette
mondialisation et de cette Europe telle
qu'elle est les Français l'ont exprimé à
chaque fois qu'on leur donne la parole
il votent non au traité contre le libre
échange 80 8 % sont compte le tafta
monsieur haruis qui est quand même un
libéral dit lui-même et je termine
là-dessus quand on dit l'Europe elle est
unie quand il s'agit de d'aller vers le
libéralisme mais pas unie quand il
s'agit de défendre l'intérêt du dernier
des plus faibles des européen parce que
dans l'accord transatlantique les études
de la Commission européenne montrent que
certains secteurs vont être favorisés et
d'autres défavorisés et devinez quels
sont les secteurs qui vont être
favorisés la machine outi allemande et
quel sont les secteurs qui vont être
défavorisés l'agroalimentaire et
l'agriculture française al moi je veux
bien que ce soit l'intérêt général de
l'Europe mais il y a pas d'intérêt
général de l'Europe qui sacrifie un bout
de l'Europe au profit d'une autre
merci il nous reste encore trois
demandes de parole après les
deux interventions relativement longues
Monsieur L noir bien monsieur le
Président c'est une invitation à ce que
je sois plus court bien je vais essayer
de vous satisfaire c'est que pour vous
c'est un
exercice écoute t il faut faire des
efforts bien monsieur laami voudrais
d'abord vous poser deux questions qui
sont en fait des questions que beaucoup
se pose autour de nous est-ce que vous
pouvez confirmer qu'au fond on est entré
dans une phase de désindustrialisation
de la France beaucoup de personnes
autour de nous n disent mais nos
industries sont en train de partir et ce
que disait Marie Noël diman est tout à
fait juste quand on visite des ateliers
industriels pas forcément de très grands
ateliers on s'intéresse aux machines
outil qui sont utilisé d'où
viennent-elles on pose toujours la
question bon rarement la France on
dirait plan machine outi ça remonte à
déjà quelques dizaines d'années on s'y a
cassé les dents mais est-ce que vous
avez pas le sentiment quand même
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de faire
ce que les Britanniques ont connu il y a
déjà pas mal d'années bon l'industrie
s'en va au bénéfice du développement des
services sans pour autant compenser bien
sûr les emplois qui sont détruits et
puis de toute de toute façon est-ce
qu'un pays comme le nôtre n'a pas besoin
d'un outil productif que ce soit
d'ailleurs dans le domaine agricole ou
dans le domaine industriel bref est-ce
que cette
désinstralisation est pour vous une
évidence est-ce qu'elle est fatale quels
sont quels sont les remède une deuxième
question que que que je me pose j'ai eu
l'occasion lorsque j'étais débuté de
participer à plusieurs sommet de l'OMC
vous étiez vous-même commissaire
européen je me souviens de Seattle et je
me souviens également de do
euh au fond on a l'impression que les
les pays
industrialisés acceptte de discuter avec
des pays émergents ça dure des années
des années pendant ce temps-là les pays
émergents s'organise à notre détriment
et puis que finalement on est toujour un
peu en retard on court un peu derrière
et qu'on se fait dans les discussions
menées au plan mondial un peu av voir
c'est un peu l'impression que que j'ai
pu ressentir maintenant deux questions
précises sur sur vous avez dit vous
étiez un homme libre donc je vous pose
des questions sur lesquelles vous allez
pouvoir vous exprimer librement vous
avez raison d'aborder la question de
l'énergie
euh est-ce que vous
considérez que la France commet une
erreur en refusant de regarder ce
qu'elle a sous ses pieds je pense au gaz
de
schiste nous avons entendu en commission
il y a un an et
demi lis loi qui avait fixé l'une de ses
priorités qui était le développement des
gazes de chiste j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler un peu sur cette question de
voir ce qui se passe aux États-Unis je
confirm votre diagnostique je l'ai
entendu tout à l'heure et deuxièmement
également dans le domaine de l'énergie
le nucléaire le nucléaire bon euh si on
cherche des secteurs où nous sommes
bons voilà le secteur nucléaire est
vraiment un domaine au moment où on
parle
dalalstom qu'est quel est quel est un
peu votre point de vue sur cette
question et avec une question
subsidiaire est-ce que vous croyez
possible euh à ce que l'Europe est une
politique de l'énergie pour ma part je
ne le crois pas chacun fait en fonction
de ses moyens et les politiques qui sont
menées me paraissent complètement
contradictoires hein mais bon enfin un
dernier point sur lequel vous allez
pouvoir vous livrer comme vous le pensez
la présidente majorité sur impulsion du
président de la République avait voté la
TV sociale quelle est votre opinion sur
ce qui avait été voté mis en place qui a
été ensuite Ôé est-ce que c'est un moyen
de faire face à la concurrence des pays
émergents merci Monsieur le nooir très
bien monsieur
oui merci monsieur le Président sera une
question simple et je P rapide même si
quand on commence comme ça c'est mauvais
signe mais là je vais essayer de oui je
je la question monsieur lami est dans la
suite de de vos propos sur la nécessité
de convergence vous avez parlé de de
convergence réglementaire concernant la
sécurité sanitaire et cetera yannick
vugrenard a parlé aussi de convergence
en ce qui concerne le droit du travail
qui me paraît effectivement des choses
tout à fait souhaitables si on veut
organiser pour ne pas dire réguler le le
commerce international en tous les cas
le rendre plus juste est-ce que vous
pensez que le moment n'est pas venu de
s'occuper aussi des atteintes graves à
l'environnement car là aussi ça peut
provoquer des distorsions de distorsion
de concurrence je je suis pas tout à
fait enfin c'est pas la même chose que
ce que vient de dire monsieur Lenoir
mais effectivement l'énergie est
importante et le coût de l'énergie est
important dans la compétitivité or quand
on a des modes d'extraction non
conventionnel des carburants
manifestement ça revient moins cher mais
manifestement aussi enfin enfin moi je
suis pas spécialiste ça peut provoquer
des dégâts sur l'environnement qui sont
importants de même que le traitement des
déchets je parle pas seulement des
déchets nuclléaire c'est pas peut-être
le plus important effectivement mais de
tous les déchets coûtent cher et donc il
faudrait pas donner une prime à ceux
qui ne prennent pas en compte cet
aspect- là alors on me dira bon B le gaz
de schiste c'est chez nous mais enfin on
sait très bien que on le sait très bien
depuis Tchernobyl que les atintes graves
à l'environnement ne s'arrêtent pas aux
frontières des uns et des autres donc il
me semble que peut-être là on devrait
commencer à prendre des mesures en terme
de d'organisation du commerce mondial
merci Madame René niikou oui je serai
brève aussi mais je voulais aborder la
question des de la législation euh qui
et et des législations qui sont qui font
partie de des discussions sur l'accord
de partenariat transatlantique il est
question que ces législations en vigueur
des deux côtés de la l'atentique se pie
aux normes du libre échange et que
lorsqu'il y a une entrave ou lorsqu'il y
a une directive prise par un
gouvernement une réglementation qui
viendrait entraver le bon fonctionnement
d'une entreprise ou limiter ses ses
gains c'est la législation en vigueur
permettrait euh d'obtenir des
compensations de la part de ces
gouvernements est-ce que ça n'est pas là
une une entrave à la bonne euh gestion à
la bonne gouvernance de chaque pays et
euh une fin à la libre administration
des pays et au profit du libre
échange
merci Monsieur l'ami vous avez seul la
parole de
renavant Monsieur L noir faites pas de
provocation
rapidement euh sur la question de la
monnaie je n'ai pas à la différence de
ce que je dirais tout à l'heure sur le
gaz de chist la même position que Louis
Gallois
euh ces affaires de taux de change
doivent être regardé avec les bons
chiffres et pas avec les chiffres de la
veille ou du lendemain qui sont les taux
nominaux changes nominaux qu'on constate
sur les marchés ce qui
importe pour la compétitivité des
économies à moyen long
terme c'est ce qu'on appelle le taux de
change effectif réel c'està-dire le taux
de change corriger des effets de prix et
pondérer en fonction de la nature des
flux commerciaux auxquels ces taux de
change
s'appliquent donc c'est ça le bon chiffr
qu'il faut regarder c'est quelque chose
qu'on fait hélas pas souvent si vous
regardez le taux d'échange effectif réel
euro- doollar il est stable sur 20 ou 30
ans et donc cette idée selon laquelle
c'est l'euro le problème à mon avis ne
tient pas si on regarde les chiffres
euh
deuxièmement je rappelle que c'est pas
la Banque centrale européenne qui a la
responsabilité de la politique de change
dans les traités européens c'est le
conseil ministres même si une politique
monétaire a des effets induits sur le
change en fonction des tons d'intérêt et
troisièmement je ne suis pas de ceux qui
brandissent comme c'est souvent le cas
dans notre hexagone chéri qui
brandissent la dépréciation et la
dévaluation comme la solution miracle à
tous nos mots comme si la dépréciation
d'une monnaie voir sa dévaluation
n'avait pas des effets
négatifs hein c'est vrai que ça peut
être bien pour la compétitivité des
exportateurs mais euh c'est nettement
moins bien euh pour la compétitivité euh
de ceux qui impimportent hein ce ce que
vous gagnez d'un côté vous le perdez de
l'autre et au fur et à mesure que le
contenu en valeur
ajoutée de vos exportations euh en
importation augmente cet effet euh finit
par finit par
s'équilibrer euh et donc euh euh ne
pensons pas si ça devait être une
tentation que l'impact économique et
social d'une dépréciation ou d'une
dévaluation de la monnaie ne fait pas un
choc sur l'économie et ne remet pas en
cause la compétitivité d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs de notre économie et
notamment et notamment sur un continent
et dans un pays qui pour des raisons que
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure doit
importer énormément d'énergie donc à mon
avis l'euro n'est pas le problème
essentiel si l'euro était le problème si
l'euro doollar était le problème
essentiel et je reviendrai l'Union
européenne n'aurait pas un surplu
industriel de 300 milliards d'euros par
an si vous regardez le cas de la France
où la France perdelle départ de marché
c'est sur la zone euro là où la monnaie
est unique où est-ce qu'elle se
débrouille plutôt pas mal c'est hors
zone euro là où on n'est pas dans la
même zone monétaire donc regardons les
chiffres aussi humblement que possible
et ceci me dit en gros que le problème
européen et français n'est pas d'ordre
monétaire sur les normes sociales
internationales vous avez tout à fait
raison d'ailleurs quand j'étais
commissaire européen j'étais porteur
d'un mandat qui consistait à disons
établir un pont un peu plus un peu moins
pointillé qu'il ne l'est entre
l'Organisation internationale du travail
et l'inationnationale du commerce je
l'ai fait quand j'étais DG de l'OMC du
point de vue de ce que je pouvais faire
c'est-à-dire de ce que je pouvais faire
sans que mon conseil général qui
représente tous les membres de
l'OMC ne me remonte les
bretelles la vérité
euh toute crue c'est que le système
international est ainsi fait que les
États décident à
l'OMC les critères de la régulation du
commerce international et il décide à
l'IT les critères de la régulation des
standards sociaux et il il décide à
l'Union internationale des
télécommunications euh la répartition
internationale des fréquences et il
décide au Codex Alimentarius qui est une
filiale de l'Organisation mondiale de la
santé et de la FAO de euh un certain
nombre de standards pour la sécurité des
aliments c'est comme ça nous vivons dans
ce système depuis
1648 les porteurs de la cohérence
entre par exemple les règles du commerce
et les règles sociales ce sont 200 état
nation
souverain et lorsque 200 état nation
souverain ce qui pas forcément tou le
cas enfin disons en gros souscrivent à
des engagements et a des disciplines en
matière de standards sociaux ils doivent
les
respecter simplement ça n'est pas une
affaire qui est traitée du côté
commercial c'est une affaire qui est
traitée du côté social l'OIT a son
propre mécanisme de règlement des
différents le peut autoriser des
sanctions sur des pays qui ne respectent
pas les standards sociaux simplement
pour des raisons diverses qui tiennent à
l'équilibre des forces à l'intérieur de
l'OIT par le mandat qui a été donné au
directeur général de l'OIT il y a 30 ans
de mettre en place un mécanisme de
règlement des différents sérieux n'a
jamais été exercé parce que il n'y a pas
disons la volonté politique chez les
membres de l'OIT d'aller jusque là hein
donc faut pas mettre ça sur le dos de
l'OMC ou de l'OIT d'ailleurs c'est la
responsabilité des état nation souverain
qui composent ces organisations ce que
peuvent faire les exécutifs et je crois
j'y ai participé et que c'est reconnu y
compris par un certain nombre de forces
syndicales mondiales j'ai été le premier
à bâtir des ponts à peu près sérieux sur
le plan des études sur le plan du
travail commun entre l'OMC et l'IT mais
disons dans la limite de ce que les
Indiens d'un côté et les Américains de
l'autre côté considérai devait être la
ligne
jaune sur les petits boulots je je n'y
reviens pas je je répète que je suis un
homme libre et que mes propos n'engagent
que moi euh et donc ça j'espère que ça
limite euh la portée euh de ces propos
mais en même temps euh euh parce que je
suis libre je dis ce que je pense pour
moi il s'agit pas de demander des
efforts aux jeunes en terme de
d'augmentation des inégalités il s'agit
de trouver du boulot pour les jeunes
point barre je n'aurais jamais dit ce
que j'ai dit si on avait un taux de
chômage des jeunes de 5 ou 10 % commment
suite ou en Allemagne jamais je n'aurais
dit ça à 25 % de chômage des jeunes je
pense que nous sommes dans une Rone
rouge et que quand on est dans une zone
rouge il faut remettre en cause quelques
lignes jaunes he aussi simple que ça je
ne vous demande pas de partager ce point
de vue je vous explique simplement
l'indignation qui est la mienne quand je
vois que mon pays tolère 25 % de chômage
des jeunes voilà c'est une
indignation j'ai été j'ai participé au
Gouvernement de la République comme vous
le savez dans les années 80 80 80 à 85
au côté de Jacques Delor à l'époque le
problème de la France c'était
l'inflation j'étais et je reste membre
du Parti
socialiste l'indexation des salaires
était une conquête sociale je me suis
battu avec du côté des salariés quand
j'étais j'ai mé syndicaliste à un moment
je trouvais à l'époque que l'indexation
des salaires était une conquête sociale
qui permettait de préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés jusqu'au jour où on
a eu une inflation de 15 % et où on
s'est aperçu que ça ne pouvait pas
tenir qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a un
gouvernement de gauche le premier depuis
très longtemps la République française a
remis en cause l'indexation des salaires
sur les prix on a remis en cause une
conquête sociale au bénéfice des
salariés les salariés ont bénéficié de
la désindexation des des salaires sur
les prix et de temps en temps il faut
accepter à mon avis d'envisager les
choses sous un autre angle parce que
sinon on reste en
calaminé chez moi en Normandie je
connais des
gamins qu' ont 15 ans et dont les
parents ont jamais eu de boulot hein ça
pour moi c'est l'orreur
l'horreur hein et je pense et je pense
et je pense que je pas que c'est une
solution miracle je dis pas que c'est
quelque chose je je dis pas que quelque
chose d'éternel mais je pense que la
priorité c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait
beaucoup d'autres
pays regardons un peu ce que font les
autres regardons pourquoi chez eux le
taux de chômage des jeunes est moins
fort que chez acceptons de temps en
temps que malgré le génie français de
Marie Noël à laquelle auquel je vais
revenir bien entendu que malgré le génie
français il y a des pays qui ont connu
des problèmes similaires au nôtres et
qui ont trouvé des solutions hein donc
la question c'est pas est-ce qu'il y a
des solutions oui il y a des solutions
la question c'est pourquoi on s'engage
pas dans ces solutions mais encore une
fois je je c'est c'est quelque chose qui
que je ressens fortement et sans doute
effectivement la pratique que j'ai eu
consiste à regarder comment font les
autres m'a sûrement imbibé
davantage sur sur le cas français
population
productivité t de croissance potentielle
de la
France effectivement dis la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est que vous avez raison dans
le cas français on estement un peuessous
de ce potentiel européen la bonne
nouvelle c'est que la raison pour
laquelle on est un peuessous n'est pas
d'ordre démographique au contraire de ce
point deue on présente Plô bien c'est du
côté de la
productivité la productivité ça se
change mieux plus vite et plus
facilement que la démographie bon mais
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle parce que on
a une faiblesse là où d'un certain point
de
vue le potentiel d'action est le plus
fort bon moi quand je suis dans une
situation comme ça je suis
content voilà bon alors j'y viens j'y
viens j'y viens mais disons c'est
vraiment une affaire de productivité
hein et et et et de compétitivité prix
et de compétitivité horors prix et et
nous savons ce qu'il en est Gallois a
tout dit et très bien sur cette question
et si ça suffit pas il suffit de de
prendre ce que le Commissariat général
au Plan à la stratégie écrit qui à mon
avis est très bonne qualité et compris
sur des points sur lesquels je je suis
pas forcément d'accord bien donc c'est
là il y a une opportunité pour la France
hein le fait que son potentiel soit plus
bas si on regarde les raisons pour
lesquelles il est plus bas alors c'est
pas forcément une mauvaise nouvelle sur
l'idiot du village global euh je ne
partage pas le point de vue de Hubert
qui le sait d'ailleurs depuis longtemps
sur les questions européennes Hubert est
un neurosceptique de talent je suis un
poste national poussif c'est comme ça
nous nous en débattons sur diverses
tribunes il se trouve que son bouquin
est sorti 3 semaines avant le mien on
part à peu près du même endroit on
arrive à peu près au même endroit
simplement c'est vrai que l'itinéraire
entre les deux n'est pas forcément même
aucun chiffre aucun chiffre ne vient à
l'appui de cette légende française ou
dis que partage certains chez nous selon
laquelle l'Europe sera l'idiot du
village global aucun chiffre un idiot du
village global qui a 300 milliards
d'euros d'excédent industriel moi je
veux bien être idiot tous les jours à ce
prix-là hein ça ça ne fait pas de sens
toutes les analyses qui ont été faites
de la politique commerciale de l'Union
euréenne et l'Union européenne comme
d'autres doit passer chez le docteur OMC
une fois tous les de 3 ans pour un
checkup complet qui fait l'objet d'un
rapport public avec des chiffres
publques et une discussion
publique l'Europe ne se protège ni mieux
ni moins bien que des animaux
comparables il n'y a aucune faiblesse
structurelle dans la politique
commerciale de l'Union donc cette idée
pour moi d'ailleurs elle elle est très
révélatrice de cette capacité que nous
avons de temps en temps à nous
autolagéler à dire vraiment on est
vraiment très mauvais on est les idiots
du village global c'est forcément c'est
pas comme ça qu'on
mobilise les troupes et je pense que
c'est une
erreur factuelle et de temps en temps il
faut regarder les faites et pas
seulement les idées les doctrines les
discours
et ça ne correspond pas à la réalité sur
la Chine est-ce que le Red minbi est
sous-évalué non il ne l''est plus hein
c'est ce que nous dit le FMI qui est qui
est disons le grand arbitre des beautés
en matière de taux de change euh le FMI
le le le Ren minidbi en taux de change
constant effectif réel s réévalué de 25
% au cours des 10 dernières années à
court terme c'est vrai ils ont un peu
décroché mais mais et et et ils savent
très bien qu'ils n'internationaliseront
pas leur monnaie ce qui est leur
objectif géostratégique en
en ayant une monnaie
faible il est vrai que le compte de
capital de la Chine n'est pas libéralisé
il y a pas besoin d'être libéralisé
d'avoir un compte de capital libéralisé
pour appartenir au FMI aussi étrange que
ça puisse paraître d'ailleurs mais c'est
comme ça les règles internationales sont
ce qu'elles sont aussi longtemps qu'on
ne leschange pas elles sont ce qu'elles
sont quant au salair chinois ils font
c'est vrai qu'ils augmentent de 15 % par
an et Marie Noë a raison de dire que la
bonne nouvelle de temps en temps c'est
que les Chinois font grève et donc petit
à petit petit à petit l'excédent
commercial chinois se réduit au fur à
mesure que la consommation intérieur
prend le relais de la croissance
chinoise sur le sur le Farm Bill
américain je suis pas en état parce que
j'ai plus les moyens l'armée technique
que j'avais quand j'étais dég de
l'OMC à ma connaissance la question de
la compatibilité du farm B américain
avec les règles existantes à OMC en
matière de
subvention n'a pas été examiné hein donc
je sais pas si a priori on peut dire que
ça colle ou que ça colle pas il faut
regarder dans le détail mais évidemment
c'est évidemment quelque chose qui devra
faire l'objet d'un examen à
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce
éventuellement d'ailleurs pourquoi pas
l'initiative de l'Union
européenne qui disons de temps en temps
un peu pas forcément la première à
soulever les questions de soutien à
l'activité agricole dans le cadre et
dans inte de l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce pour des raisons qu'on comprend
bien bon Marie Noël on va pas se lancer
dans un grand débat
public ce que tu appelles libéralisation
j'appelle ouverture des échanges et et
c'est une nuance sémantique importante
ouverture ouvrir c'est ouvrir
libéraliser au sens de déréguler c'est
autre chose hein et là il y a des
petites confusions sémantiques auquel il
faut faire attention en gros l'ouverture
des échanges a donné de très bons
résultats
les économies ouvertes marchent mieux
que les économies fermées ce qui s'est
passé depuis 30 ans a formidablement
réduit la pauvreté dans le monde il est
vrai au prix de la croissance
d'inégalité à l'intérieur des pays c'est
le point de vue que je développe dans la
première partie de ce petit livre où je
parle de la mondialisation Janus et là
c'est bon côté et là c'est mauvais côté
je n'ai d'ailleurs jamais été un avocat
de jeun ne sais tropquelle
mondialisation paradisiaque ou heureuse
euh il y a des forces en contraire il y
a des courants il y a des vents et puis
il faut savoir les prendre à la fin du
fin c'est c'est décision humaine il n'y
a pas de
facilité et donc il est vrai que le
rapport entre disons l'économie les
marchés et les sociétés et notamment les
sociétés politiques et remis en cause
par cette phase là de globalisation
comme il l'a d'ailleurs été par les
phases de globalisation
précédentes il y a un sujet difficile
articulation entre de désencastrement
comme disait polani entre entre
l'économie et la société au niveau
mondial je suis de ceux qui pensent
qu'il y a des solutions à ce problème et
notamment que les systèmes qui offrent
davantage de solidarité sociale que les
autres sont meilleurs pour traiter cette
question c'est pas un hasard si les pays
les plus compétitifs sur cette planète
sur le moyen long terme sont ceux qui
ont des systèmes sociaux les plus
sophistiqués il y a d'autres facteurs
qui interviennent mais celui-là
intervient certainement quant au juste
échange 100 fois pour comme je l'écrit
d'ailleurs dans ce petit livre à une
condition c'est que les partenaires à
l'échange se mettent d'accord sur ce qui
est
juste ce qui en gros nous ramène à la
case départ hein c'est un concept
formidable sauf que si on doit discuter
tous les deux de ce qu'est le juste
échange faudra commencer par se mettre
d'accord sur ce qui est juste ce qui
suppose d'un certain point de vue le
problème
résolu et donc on en est on on en est on
en est pas là quant au résonnement sur
l'Europe cadre favorable aux autres et
pas à nous typique de cette
autolagellation française qui consiste à
penser qu'on est des mauvais qu'on est
des médiocres qu'on se fait avoir par
les autres et quand c'est pas la Chine
c'est l'Allemagne et quand c'est pas
l'Allemagne c'est Bruxells et quand
c'est pas Bruxelles c'est les immigrés
quand c'est pas les immigrés c'est les
Arabes il y a toujours il y a toujours
raison extérieure à nos problèmes
l'Allemagne et j'ai connu ça quand
j'étais à Bruxelles après la
réunification a connu des années
épouvantables l'Allemagne était l'homme
malade de l'Europe dans la même Europe
que nous
elle était malade plus rien allait comme
chez nous et puis qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont pas changé l'Europe pour ça
ils ont fait une opération qui s'appelle
standor Deutschland et ils ont pris le
taureau par les cornes et ils ont petit
à petit réussi à résoudre un certain
nombre de leurs problèmes donc avec le
même cadre l'Allemagne est sorti de la
Moïse alors que nous n'en sommes pas
sortis donc ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
l'Europe qui est responsable nous
avons nous
avons s'il vous plaît monsieur rotillo
pas de provocation nous avons mais nous
avons nous avons nous avons nos propres
problèmes reconnaissons-le et ne mettons
pas ces problèmes toujours sur le dos
encore une fois de cette mondialisation
de la Chine de l'Allemagne de Bruxelles
aussi longtemps aussi longtemps que nous
resterons dans cet état
d'esprit qui consiste à attribuer
l'essentiel de nos problèmes ailleurs ce
qui commode intellectuellement notre
pays continuera la dérive qu'il a entamé
il y a 40 ans avec le déficit des
finances publiques
qu'il a entamé il y a 30 ans avec le
chômage de masse et qu'il a entamé il y
a 10 ans avec la détérioration de sa
compétitivité on peut faire les deux pe
l'essentiel l'essentiel de nos problèmes
et chez nous et je dénonce je regrette
pour ma part cette tendance que je
constate dans notre pays à mettre la
racine de nos problèmes sur le dos des
autres je pense que c'est une attitude
intellectuelle erronée et que quand on a
une attitude intellectuelle erronée on
n'agit pas dans le bon sens quant au
génie français il est là il n'a rien de
disqualifier il doit au contraire
s'employer et s'engager je vais dans
quelques minutes remettre à Monsieur
Jean-Pascal Tricoire le prix du
financier de l'année voilà une
entreprise ch électrique qui a pas
toujours connu disons un dessin
industriel formidable si on songe à ce
que fut
cosoloir voilà une entreprise
mondialisée qui fait
95 % de son chifffre d'affaires hors de
France qui est un succès formidable qui
est dans un métier d'avenir qui est
positionné sur les marchés émergents
typique du génie français bien que
Jean-Pascal triquir ne soit pas un
produit de l'élite des grandes écoles ce
qui est peut-être d'ailleurs une des
raisons une des raisons pour lesqu qui
absolument et et voilà un vandéen qui
vient Hong Kong alors je je je je sais
bien je sais bien qu'un vendéen qui vit
à Hong Kong ça dérange chez nous mais
c'est une des raisons principales de son
succès et donc il y a il y a manière de
réussir et et d'accord avec Marie Noël
pour dire que c'est un écosystème encore
une fois ne restons pas sur des formules
quel est le bon niveau d'appréhension de
cet écosystème et et aussi longtemps
qu'on n' pas répondu à cette question on
n' pas beaucoup avancé sur la
désinstrualalisation bien sûr qu' a une
désinstrualisation mais l'essentiel
vient des marges insuffisantes des
entreprises françaises
elles n'ont pas de marge suffisante
elles ne font pas assez de profit hein
c'est quand un socialdémocrat parle de
profit ici c'est toujours dangereux mais
la vérité économique c'est que les
marges des entreprises français sont
insuffisantes qu'elles n'ont pas de quoi
investir et donc qu'un certain nombre
d'activités se font ailleurs il n'y a
là-dedans rien de Fatal hein et regardez
le ce qu'on fait les Britanniques hein
les Britanniques étaient des mauvais
dans l'industrie il y a 20 ans et nous
on était des bons la part de PNB
provenant de l'industrie est plus forte
en Bretagne chez eux qu'elle ne l' chez
nous bien donc rien de Fatal mais mais
mais si les marges des entreprises
restent ce qu'elles sont alors notre
tissu entrepreneurial et c'est vrai dans
l'industrie comme dans les services sauf
que l'industrie est par nature plus
exposée à la concurrence
internationale aussi 60 % de notre
économie c'est des services 40 % c'est
autre chose l'industrie étant plus
exposée à la concurrence internationale
la faiblesse de ses marges la fragilise
d'avantage du point de vue de la
poursuite des activités et de la
compétitivité que ça n'est le cas dans
les services sur de je ne sais pas j'ai
tendance à à partager la position de
Louis Gallois mais je ne sais pas et au
fond on donne pas les moyens de
savoir bien donc je ne sais pas et je
n'ai pas les moyens de savoir je peux
peux pas en dire
plus sur le nucléaire je crois qu'on ne
peut pas se passer du
nucléaire accessoirement c'est une
énergie qui émet relativement moins de
CO2 même si on prend l'intégralité de la
chaîne je pense que c'est un avantage
comparatif et ça doit faire partie du
mix énergétique français d'accord avec
vous pour dire que au niveau européen
les politiques il y a pas aujourd'hui de
politique énergétique européenne que
c'est le bazar et à mon avis c'est trop
le bazar il y a forcément des
différences mais elles sont aujourd'hui
excessive et là c'est une question de
volonté politique y compris de la part
de la Commission européenne qui devrait
savoir de temps en temps mettre sur la
table des projets de décision à faire
décider à la majorité qualifié sur ces
sujet hein ce que ce qu'elle n'a pas
fait sur la TVA sociale euh j'ai sociale
ou pas la question c'est de savoir si
une Haos de la TVA est une bonne
solution hein c'est pas qu'elle soit
sociale ou pas sociale c'est toujours la
même c'est toujours la même après après
après la question c'est est-ce que vous
faites peser sur le
consommateur davantage du poids du du
coût du système de redistribution c'est
ça la question bien le consommateur va
payer la TVA pas me dire que c'est pas
le consommateur qui paye la TVA alors
mais le consommateur va payer davantage
de TVA donc c'est un problème qui se
pose pas seulement pour la TVA sociale
est-ce que on doit faire porter le poid
du financement de la redistribuation
française que ce soit par l'État les
collectivités locales ou que ce soit par
des régimes sociaux est-ce qu'on doit le
faire porter davantage sur le
consommateur moi j'ai tendance à penser
queoui parce que je pense que c'est
quelque chose à moyen long terme qui est
de nature à nous aider à redresser notre
compétitivité hein c'est ce que je pense
mais de là à faire une recommandation en
disant de combien de points et ce qu'on
retire d'ailleurs pour la rajouter là je
nen sais c'est rien mais si vous voulez
c'est ça ça n'a de sens qu'à l'intérieur
de d' d'un concept général qui est sur
quel acteur économique le financement de
notre système de redistribution doit-il
peser sur l'environnement entièrement
d'accord il y a évidemment une question
importante qui est celle de l'empreinte
environnementale de nos systèmes de
production et on sait bien qu'elle est
pas soutenable à terme de 20 30 ou 40
ans
euh on sait bien que l'énergie la
consommation d'énergie mais pas
seulement d'énergie aussi d'eau par
exemple est est un des problèmes et ça
c'est soit vous régulez ça de manière
multilatérale c'est le sens des
négociations internationales sur
changement climatique qui piétine depuis
12 ou 20 ans soit vous le réglez de
manière unilatérale du type je prends
une mesure à la frontière qui est
destiné à équilibrer l'empreinte carbone
de mes importations avec avec l'emprinte
carbone de ma production
domestique dans le cas européen
malheureusement ça ne marche pas pour
une raison simple c'est que l'empreinte
carbone des exportations européennes est
plus mauvaise que celle des importations
européennes contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens
penseent l'Europe globalement est
spécialisée dans le commerce
international dans des industries dans
les secteurs qui sont très carbonés on a
parlé de la machine outil deux fois ce
ce matin en voilà un excellent exemple
il y a pas plus carboné qu'une machine
outil même chose pour l'automobile même
chose pour les assierss spéciaux et donc
si vous faites le bilan euh commerce
extérieur européen en terme de carbone
et que vous allez dans cette direction
en gros la seule conclusion logique que
vous pouvez tirer c'est que vous devez
subventionner les importations euh
européennes ce qui est assez
contreintuitif euh bon mais encore une
fois pour aller dans cette direction il
faut regarder les chiffres de temps en
temps et savoir où on met les pieds la
la voie royale reste une solution
globale et j'espère qu'on j'espère qu'on
oui j'espère qu'on finira par la trouver
sans sans je de
mot
madame ni coup bon sur le sur les
négociations transatltiques je crois que
j'ai expliqué en gros quel était le
contexte hein il s'agit de
négocier de la convergence réglementaire
avec toutes les difficultés ça présente
et toutes les opportunités que ça
présente sur l'affaire du mécanisme de
règlement des
différents qui est effectivement sur la
table de la négociation à la demande des
Américains qui est ce qu'on appelle
invester to state dispute settlement qui
est un système de règlement de
contentieux qui permet contrairement à
ce qui se passe par exemple à l'OMC ou
conformément à ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur des pays à une
entreprise d'attaquer un
souverain lorsque l'entreprise considère
que le non respect par ce souverain des
dispositions de l'accord crée un dommage
au détriment de
l'entreprise donc une procédure
spéciale que les Américains en général
mettent dans leurs traités
bilatéraux mon sentiment mais encore une
fois qui n'engage que moi je suis
mandaté par personne sur cette affaire
c'est que je vois bien l'intérêt d'un
mécanisme de ce genre si l'Europe doit
asser un traité de libre échange avec le
Sri Lanka le Népal ou la Birmanie parce
que Jeur pas forcément tendance à faire
confiance à la justice Bierman népalaise
ou sri-lancaise si je suis investisseur
là-bas et que j'ai un sérieux problème
donc l'idée d'avoir un dispositif
juridictionnel
séparé me paraît disons assez justifié
si je suis investisseur et que je veux
que s'il y a un contentieux sur mes
activités et mon investissement ce soit
soit fait selon les règles normales du
droit bon dans le cas euro-américain
j'ai tendance à penser que même s'il est
compliqué le système judiciaire
juridique américain est en gros de
qualité standard et que le système
européen judiciaire est en gros de
qualité standard les entreprises
européennes peuvent attaquer le
gouvernement américain sur l'espace
américain les entreprises américaines
peuvent attaquer les gouvernements enfin
disons les entités souveraines
européennes sur l'espace européen donc a
priori je ne vois pas disons la
l'utilité je vois pas l'utilité a priori
je ne vois pas l'utilité d'un mécanisme
de ce genre hein autrement dit je pense
que les européens peuvent faire
confiance à la justice américaine s'il y
a un litige et que les Américains
peuvent faire confiance à la justice
européenne
elles ont bonne réputation elles sont
parfois un peu compliquées mais elles
ont en tout cas pas la réputation de
prendre des décisions dans le sens de
celui qui donne la plus grosse enveloppe
donc voilà ma voilà ma position sur ce
sujet
merci je vous remercie d'avoir passé
plus d'une heure et demi avec nous et
permettre ces échanges en tous les cas
même si sur un certain nombre de points
nous avons j'ai bien compris quelques
différences d'approche euh c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir le point de
vue dit
complémentaire Marie Noël s'est enrichi
ce matin je suis persuadé
donc conforé conforté surprise surprise
bien je vous remercie chage des jeun
c'est un chiffre sur les jeunes sur le
marché si tu rapportes à la classe d'âge
tu te rendras compte que le chômage des
jeunes en France est plutôt dans la
moyenne base de l'Union européenne parce
que nous avons beaucoup de gens
scolarisés longtemps alors après on peut
dire est-ce qu'ils sont ont tous bien
scolarisé où il fut non mais je m'excuse
mais c'est plutôt c'est plutôt quand
même positif que le niveau scolaire des
trucs je ne veux pas dire que le chômage
des jeunes n'est pas un problème ah bon
au moins sur ce point on est d'accord
j'espère qu'on est d'accord sur le fait
que c'est un énorme
problème sûr mais je ne crois absolument
pas la solution mais la théorie que la
France serait complètement déflagration
par rapport aux autres je compare au
autres c'est tout voilà pour cette
audition de Pascal Lam qui a donc été
iné par la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat le 7 mai dernier
vous avez pu l'entendre Pascal l'i a été
notamment entendu comme directeur
général de l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce un poste qu'il a occupé pendant
10 ans mais vous avez pu l'entendre
Pascal ami est également un économiste
reconnu et très favorable à
l'intégration européenne vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaires